after institution destroyed this
revolution of course
began in academia at the schools higher
education mostly
now moving downward into high schools
and has been
particularly virulent in private schools
the more prestigious the worst
latest example comes from new york city
the dalton school
at dalton more than a hundred faculty
members have released an eight-page
anti-racism manifesto
with proposals so lunatic that it's hard
to believe they're real for example they
want the school to pay student debt for
incoming black faculty reroute 50
percent of all donations to the school
to new york city's public schools
eliminate all advanced placement courses
if any race does worse than any other
and so on and so on and so on
scott johnston broke the story his blog
the naked dollar he's the author of the
book campus land we talked about that
which is a great book
he joins us again tonight scott thanks
so much for coming on
give us an overview of this
conflagration
at the dalton school in new york and why
it matters
uh well the faculty came up with this
manifesto if you will in august and i
think the school has tried to keep it
under wraps since then i know some
parents have seen it
now everyone's seen it um and i would
urge everybody not
to take my word or your word for any of
this
um i know the the board had an emergency
meeting after
my blog the naked dollar printed out
this entire manifesto
and they're writing it off as just a
right-wing hit job
don't take my word for it or your word
for it go go on my website or anywhere
else and go
go read the whole thing it's about eight
pages long
and it's as if it was written by a
freshman sociology major at berkeley
there's mandatory diversity plot lines
in school plays they want to hire 12
diversity
officers bear in mind this is a
reasonably small
k through 12 school 12 full-time
diversity officers i
i i'm sort of mystified what they would
do all day
the answer to that is they're going to
have to find ever more nuanced examples
of racism to to justify their jobs
although put in context by the way my
alma mater yale has
150 full-time diversity officers
they want no more ap classes by 2023
if the black students have not uh fully
uh caught up with white students in
terms of their qualifications for those
classes
interestingly i'm i'm told some of the
parents who had no problem with a lot
about this other woke stuff
when it got to that one said oh my god
i'll have to pull my kid if if it comes
to that
um they want required anti-racism
statements
from everybody at the school which
is eerily reminiscent of the the
struggle sessions during the cultural
level
revolution with the red guard egging you
on where you had to confess to thought
crimes
um honestly what's so sad about this is
that
um you know while it burn it burnishes
the the woke credentials of the the
white hierarchy in a place like dalton
and mind you this isn't just about
dalton as you've been pointing out this
is
across institutional america it hurts
the very people it's trying to help by
creating
by by by anointing them with permanent
victim status
and it codifies race as a dividing
principle uh we're not
moving to a post-racial society in fact
martin luther king is is on the outs
with this crowd because
uh he advocated a color blind society
and that's not at all
what this crowd wants anymore
well and it's also destroying the
rationale for the school i mean these
schools are incredibly expensive
people send their kids there because
they think they'll be improved and
they'll get in
to some selective college but you got to
kind of wonder if they're not sowing the
seeds of their own
elimination here who would send a kid to
a school like that
well none of the parents will speak
publicly because
those that do have a problem with any of
this are terrified to say anything you
know because
because yale because harvard um
i a school is the sum of its teachers
more than anything else
and this is reflective of the sort of
people
places like dalton are hiring as
teachers they are
full-on woke and again don't believe me
go read the statement uh if you think
this is the product
of rational minds there must be
something wrong with you and i hope and
i hope that our viewers will because
it's
it's really stunning rippling with
race hostility and really poisonous
scott i appreciate you coming on tonight
thank you
thanks